sans surprise et contrairement à ce qui
avait été promis à l'époque l'état
d'urgence de 2015 ouart a bien fini par
s'immiscer durablement dans le droit
commun le présent projet de loi vise à
pérenniser à compléter les instruments
de prévention de la commission d'actes
de terrorisme dont le législateur a doté
l'autorité administrative à l'issue de
l'état d'urgence est alors que le niveau
de la menace demeure toujours très élevé
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
au moins c'est assumer on peut ainsi
noter dans ce projet de loi dit relatifs
à la prévention d'actes de terrorisme et
renseignements la perpétuation des mika
ou mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et de surveillance un
système d'assignation à résidence pour
les personnes suspectées de sympathie de
terroristes ou encore les visites
domiciliaires le nouveau nom des
perquisitions administratives qui sont
désormais soumises à l'accord de
l'autorité judiciaire
la nouvelle loi pérennise également la
possibilité d'instaurer des périmètres
de sécurité en cas d'événement un risque
ou le pouvoir administratif de fermer
des lieux de culte des mesures qui n'ont
guère satisfait les observateurs du
respect des droits humains
ce texte vise à pérenniser et même à
renforcer les mesures antiterroristes
exceptionnelles dont nous demandons
l'abrogation depuis plusieurs années car
comme nous l'avons démontré à de
multiples reprises dans nos enquêtes
elle porte atteinte au droit à un procès
équitable au droit à la vie privée et
familiale ou encore au droit au travail
mais si vous avez bien retenu le nom de
cette loi vous avez compris qu'elle
comporte un autre volet relatif aux
renseignements cette fois avec le
renforcement des boîtes noires des
algorithmes de traitement automatisé des
données de communication électronique de
l'ensemble de la population transitant
sur les réseaux des opérateurs de
télécoms et des fournisseurs d'accès à
internet en clair une écoute généralisée
nos l'objectif est de détecter les
germes d'éventuelles menaces terroristes
selon l'étude d'impact de la nouvelle
loi ces algorithmes aurait généré 1739
alerte pour l'année 2020
le texte pérennise ces boîtes noires
tout en incluant désormais les url c'est
à dire les adresses des sites que nous
consultons toutes ces données de
connexion seront de plus partagés entre
services en fonction
de leur intérêt et conserver des années
durant notamment à des fins de recherche
et développement notamment en
intelligence artificielle un futur de la
surveillance française qui là encore n'a
pas fait que des enthousiastes
les mesures de surveillance sont
disproportionnées et autorise le
placement sur surveillance de larges
portions de la population française sur
la base de motifs très large sans même
qu'un juge ait donné son accord
or aucune disposition dans le projet de
loi actuel le relatifs à la prévention
d'actes de terrorisme et au
renseignement n'est prévu pour résoudre
ces problèmes
au contraire les mesures présentées
pourrait aggraver ces atteintes
le projet de loi semble pourtant avoir
fédéré les élus puisqu'il a été adoptée
à l'assemblée nationale par une très
large majorité de députés y compris
socialistes et ce malgré la procédure
accélérée malgré les délais entre la
présentation du texte en conseil des
ministres et le vote des députés à peine
plus d'un mois très court au regard de
l'importance et de la complexité du
sujet je rappelle que l'étude d'impact à
elle seule fait plus de 250 pages et que
le conseil d'état tout comme la cnil se
sont prononcés sur le texte en émettant
parfois certaines réserves le vote du
sénat est prévu lui dans moins de deux
semaines
et là non plus l'issue ne fait guère de
doute renforçant encore un peu plus les
prérogatives sécuritaire de l'état